so welcome to don't push the red button
off you remember a game by the name of
don't press the button this might be
similar I don't know this was pretty
newly released and I saw and I'm like
I'm always down for a game that's about
pushing a big red button I like that a
lot so I'm gonna push this big red
button and I'm gonna see what's going on
with it I don't like the ominous explode
he's in the background the ominous
exploding seemed to suggest that
something is going to be exploding all
over me and I don't like that
let's see what happens wise okay alright
red a mouse button to push a big red a
button horse or a bond post or a bond
wrong rabbit was a red button push the
red button push push button push to
Lukens GD rotate a stay presion el botón
Rojo a puia sur le bouton Rouge bruit on
Cape Dara e to Radha hoppin spin Gare
ill pill sant a row so push the red
button drug op de road na presión aobut
a over mellow pushy shocked if flung go
Nichkhun do it do lock-on pulang Bhutan
non Newton well what what the hell
travel to Spain visit our web a suit
okay I want you to push the red button
my favorite alright will you push the
button for me push the button button
alright well I think they might 10 out
of 10 doctors recommend pushing the red
button anytime I hear that one of my
friends hasn't pushed the red button I
cut them out of my life immediately I'm
a millennial and between all my snapchat
and tumblr I thought those tumblr
sniffing at first I just don't have time
in my life can you quiet down with the
choir I just don't have time in my life
for people who aren't socially conscious
enough to push the button I mean it's
the right thing to do paid for by the
foundation for a better red button oh
man I don't want to do that trainers
hate him press the red button to learn
the secret of quick I don't think that
was his proper quote red button
keep calm and push duh button anyone
who'd push the red button it's all right
in my book dermatologist hater he's 50
she does not look like 21 she looks like
a moist grandmother if I ever saw one
use this one weird trick to turn back
time press the red button whoa well
you're not really putting a good
argument out there I was so skeptical
Bob pushing the red button but now I've
never been happier
my skin is clear my eyesight is better I
have an incredible amount of focus and
then my love alive whoa
love one complete now as you can now
push the right button I can I recommend
pushing the button more is the best
decision I've ever made I have three
doctorates in theoretical science and
all my tier two tells me that a
logically minded person should
absolutely push the red button
the evidence is overwhelming and then
even not a firm understanding and faith
in science will not hesitate to push the
button it burns
trust me I'm like three doctors oh well
uh huh oh I don't like the way the
button follows me best button pusher
your name here well become who you are
push the button
Oh Who am I push it oh well huh well I
don't know guys I don't know guys do you
think I should push it I mean I haven't
really heard a compelling argument that
this button is gonna be good for me I
live here it is that you know there's a
lot of people that believe in the button
but you know Obama here he's just saying
button and I feel like that's a bit of a
cop-out I mean I don't even know if
chica would like me to push the button
to be honest I feel a lot of peer
pressure here and I don't think that's
good for anybody what do you think what
do you think do you think I should
what's that huh oh what's that
oh really you think that that's that's
like the like button and you gotta smash
it as hard as you can
wait no what's that it's red like the
dislike button oh no you don't smash
that no matter what you do wait what's
that oh but do you need to try oh I need
to trust you I need to trust and
understand that you know what's best for
me don't you oh yes you do oh yes I do
you can talk but I can talk too oh my
god
don't push it push it oh my god who do I
believe who do I trust who do I even
approach I don't know I'm so torn
between two lovers of mine Oh health oh
well
ow I don't know what ow ow my soul ow
it really hurts don't do ow oh ow my
heart wait my heart's trying to talk to
me no wait I got trust my gut on this
one don't push the button all right I
usually go with my gut I try not to
follow my heart so you shut up there oh
okay I guess I'm not dying then I guess
it's fine all right so I'm caught
between my gut my heart and my two
lovers here anybody else want to chime
in while I'm at it
[ __ ] you got anything to say oh oh oh
he's not with her what I need you oh the
Tootsie's are out of commission okay but
my butt of course but what do you think
listen I've always known what's best for
you mark you've always trusted me and
I've always had your back no matter what
through thick and thin I've always been
there for you but we can't make this
decision for you
you gotta believe in yourself you gotta
stand by your convictions and all always
always be there to support you when you
need me most ah thanks but man but
really knows how to talk to me but
really knows the best things my penis Oh
penis [ __ ] the button
okay no I'm not gonna do that but thank
you my but only says crap how dare you
how dare you talk about my butt like
that my butt has been with me my whole
life he's always been there when I need
a seat
my butt's got me what I need to open a
door when my hands are full
my butt's got me so don't you don't you
dare don't don't you I'm disappointed in
you
I've never been more disappointed in you
but I am so you know what I'm not gonna
push this button I'm gonna listen to my
butt and I'm gonna know I'm gonna know
once and for true once and for the true
that I listen to the right part of my
body and that's my butt my butt is not
talking [ __ ] it's not no abscess not
while my ass is crazy my ass is out of
this world my ass is in Shana butt my
butt knows what it's talking about I'm
not gonna push this button cuz but ten
but that leads me to believe that the
butt might know what the button can do
for me and so I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna listen to his voice I'm gonna
listen to myself all these other parts
of my body they don't know what's best
for me but I know I know what's best for
me
my butt is an arrogant liar maybe you're
an arrogant liar maybe you you ever
think about that maybe you maybe you're
an arrogant liar maybe my butt who only
told me to believe in myself who
everyone else here had an opinion
everyone out door you doing like the
lightboard
don't like the dislike button everybody
had an opinion except for my feet
the Tootsie's were out of commission but
my butt my butt told me to believe in
myself as a whole as one whole human
being you know you can't you can't buy a
friend that good you can't buddy
you can't you know when your friends
have been there for you from the very
beginning what your friends have
supported you through think it fit you
guys to pause it back who are you
[Music]
participant there is a red button in the
middle of the testing area it is
required of you to push the red button
go ahead push it push the red button go
to the button
see the button gaze upon the glory of
the button reach out and push the red
button with your hand
any hand breech out feel the red button
under your fingers and with everything
in your being push it push it push it
push it push it push it push it push it
push it push it push it push it push the
red button for the love of God push the
red button why are you being so selfish
it is so simple I need you to do this
for me this is the last time I'm going
to ask you push the red button I am
going to count to three and if you have
n to push that button so help me one two
two and a half two and three quarters
two point nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine oh you have to
be kidding me what is wrong with you can
you understand me push the button push
it I don't think you understand me at
all push the button no nothing what a
waste of time
well why me I was waiting for you to
finish talking okay all right well I
mean like you didn't give me a
compelling reason like that was the
thing like I was looking for a
compelling reason I'm a reasonable guy
look I'm a reasonable guy I would
reasonably reasonably I would reasonably
push the button if you could just give
me a compelling argument to do so I'm
not I'm not like a follower I don't just
do what the the the the trends are I
don't just do what people like ask of me
to do I I would do it though if you like
do you have a pamphlet like on the
button like do you have like some
information that I could look up on that
I could do some real how long do you
need an answer like can I get an answer
back tomorrow on the button like I all
right well I guess he's gone I guess
he's not listening me anymore but anyway
yeah so um yeah I'm not gonna push it I
guess he's just gone you guys want me to
go through the language again I could
probably do that true concede erode ate
a stay I don't know how to pronounce
that um let's see there's a pie symbol
in there and that's just intimidating as
a lambda I think Rotato Koch Evo Pi
Lambda ooh all right I think so where's
the Korean on here
why is there no Korean on there you know
that's that was that was what I was
worried about okay all right okay all
right I get it that's what I was worried
about there's no Korean on here did you
know that I'm half Korean see I didn't I
wasn't able to understand it is the
thing I didn't understand what you want
I bet the Korean the Korean translation
would really really give me a compelling
argument as to why I need to push that
button but I just it's not here there's
no Korean here there's that I believe
it's Chinese that's Japanese but nah no
Korean here unfortunately no the less
yeah I guess I I guess I'll just never
know we'll never know you'll never know
I'll never know we'll just never know hi
I do like the lights though the lights
are real nice like if I had to admit
like the theming of this room is this
like an escape room
oh I love escape rooms I've only been on
one hello hi what's oh oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey whoa whoa hey whoa hey
whoa I'm sorry I do not have an
inflation fetish you didn't know you
don't you don't need to do that at all I
don't know what your listener you just
gotta keep oh you're just gonna keep
going oh um well listen number one thank
you
first and foremost thank you I'm
flattered
but number two no not into that so wow
you are you're big you are big but I'm
okay I'm honestly I'm good just hard
pass seriously it's okay you can stop at
any moment now I'm very impressed
ah good excellent good great well done
I'm a-saying here I like this hallway
it's real like secluded I like it it's
good I'm uh yeah I'm okay so you just
you do whatever you I don't like that
that's can I can I school I think I left
my think I left my phone or wallet in
there could I all right you know I'm not
gonna okay you uh you just you're oh
okay Wow
that okay all right well cool that was
great trick I will admit that was
wonderful trick but to be honest I just
uh YUM I'm okay yeah how you guys doing
how you are you good yeah you good hi
sorry I haven't been paying attention a
while I got distracted there's uh you
know a lot of demands on my time as of
late so I just don't know what people
want of me or what to do so uh yeah I I
did the for tonight thing that was
pretty cool I met some cool people there
so that was nice yeah I lost I lost I
lost real bad actually I I lost like the
worst we we did very poorly but that's
okay I'm just sad that they didn't cut
to me when I was building my subscribe
to market Blair sign hi Joel and I we
had this plan we had a plan the second
round we were gonna build a big old sign
that says subscribe - markiplier but we
landed we landed where there was a lot
of trees the woods area and we were
trying to harvest and I
an off to go get a gun just in case and
then wouldn't you know it someone came
up in cha Joel I couldn't believe it I
just I couldn't believe it I couldn't
believe it I just couldn't believe it it
was it was something it was something
like out of a nightmare he he got killed
and then I had half the would I needed I
was building sub I got the number two in
there I gotten an M in there and then
like ran out of time it was a strategy
and then they didn't cut to us at all so
they that was bad
oh yeah storm killed me because I was
building I was trying to build it in the
storm got me in the second round even
even moose elk moose ilk tried to come
help me he was he was he was in into
this but then I think he was trying to
he was trying to cuz I got the em I got
the em I think he was trying to spell
moose elk instead of markiplier I think
he was trying to swoop in and get that
from me but he didn't finish it either
he he got killed by the storm as well so
we were working together on that one we
were working together he was he was my
my buddy there he was my buddy but uh
yeah last they didn't they didn't get us
they didn't get us it's almost like they
didn't want to see us it's almost like
they didn't want to show us on camera
for what we were doing there's a room
getting thinner I don't know is it
losing weight I don't think so I think
just staring at the same thing for so
long you start to you start to channel
some channel some weird psychosis going
on here but uh seems to be good so far
this fun though like I gotta admit like
of all the games that I played this is
probably it's probably the most
enjoyable experience that I've had this
is like oh he's like yes yes I I'm like
I'm really excited about this one the
button makes me taller ah well you know
I'm comfortable with my height I'm
pretty good I'm pretty okay with what I
have
oh hey are you are you are you are you
on my face why why are you on my face
like oh geez alright that's a little
rude
alright I think you listen to my dick a
little too much there you don't need to
be this assertive about things I don't
don't like the Olympian okay alright
well you know this is real cool and all
but the the throbbing I think the
throbbing is really what I don't like
about it is just the pulsating in and
out motion something very look just like
look I don't deal with it preferably I
really rather know oh oh well thank you
thank you for respecting my boundaries I
really do a previous way no it's hang on
wait no you you're still in my face it
just doesn't look like it if I if I were
to click right now it would it would
push the button and see that's just this
is trickery that's like a bad ad that's
like that's like someone like trying to
coerce you into hitting a like button or
something like that that's that's just
not cool come on I mean there's all I'm
all for asking the asking was nice
implies but you're tricking me you're
trying to trick me and I don't
appreciate that none at all I don't I
just oh now you're gone ok I called you
out on your [ __ ] now you're back to
normal
oh I see how it is okay alright well
then thank you for listening again I
guess
thank you I always want to give credit
where credit is due and I really
appreciate you doing that I'm still
peeved but you know at least I can be a
man about it and grown up about it you
know not saying of being a man about is
better than being a woman about it or
anything else but I'm saying right now
me being a man like I'm gonna be a man
about it I'm not I don't want to bring
in like I didn't I sorry if I assumed
your gender at all I did that's not what
I was should I should I ask
alright next up anyway you know what I
mean like you know what I mean right you
know what I mean I'm not I'm not trying
to be insulting here I'm trying to be
accommodating and I'm trying to be
understanding III try to be open-minded
I'm not I'm not judging in any way it's
just like you were trying to trick me
and I'm gonna I'm gonna be the bigger
I'm gonna be the bigger human that that
work oh you're not oh [ __ ] you're not
human I guess I'll just
I'll uh I'll just um let's just start
over like let's start over as if like
we're let's just start completely over
this this whole experience has been like
I I wasn't I wasn't approaching with the
right mindset I think we can kick off to
like a better start yeah we have a lot
in common we have IVA I'm wearing a red
shirt you're a red button we have a lot
in common that's really cool you and I
we can get along like this is wholly
understandable au or red you want to be
pushed I'm wearing red and I don't want
to push you so you know we're where we
are have differences we actually have
more in common than you think
get a second opinion oh you know I I
don't need a second opinion unless I got
my second opinion from my butt my butt
told me to listen to me and I stand by
my convictions once I make a decision
like I'm stuck to that decision I like
if people gave me a good reason like if
people gave me a good reason like people
explained some facts I asked for a
pamphlet awhile ago but I didn't get a
pamphlet so I like I'm a reasonable
person but I also I'm a man of
convictions I'm a I'm a human I'm a I'm
I'm an entity of convictions
I am a being of convictions doesn't
really matter if I'm a man or not which
I am that's I am a man but I'm of
convictions glad I cleared that up for
all you if you mr. button want to
explain to me the why how where and with
whom of which this would benefit me that
would be great now it that would be
really great the button will make me
extra swole I I'm pretty I'm good like a
like I said I body positivity I'm very
comfortable with Who I am with what I am
I'm like I'm rock solid Oh
Oh
[Music]
well one of these guys is saying don't
push me I'm gonna respect those
boundaries see these guys can talk but
you know I'm not comfortable with
meeting new people right now I was
having a one-on-one with mr. button here
or miss uh um I was having a one-on-one
with button here and there's suddenly a
lot of people came in I like I hate to
be this guy I hate to be this guy
I like ordinarily I would love to like
take pictures like sign whatever you
want ordinarily I'm very happy to meet
fans but right now like it's kind of an
important just one-on-one moment do you
guys understand like I was uh I was
gonna go okay thank you thank you oh
thank you like I hate I hate being that
I hate being that person I don't want to
I don't want to be that that guy most of
the time ordinarily I'm very happy to
meet whoever but you know thank you
thank you anyway you were saying read
can I call you read hmm okay all right
well you know I feel like I feel like
this I feel like there could be more
dialog in between us I feel like you
know I'm good at carrying a conversation
I am I really am sometimes I put my foot
in my put my [ __ ] in my mouth but uh if
it's just gonna be you and us we got to
talk at some point so is this about the
whole like gender thing cuz I I'll admit
it my tootsies were way in my mouth at
that point and I was just all over the
place and I was trying to recover and I
was backpedaling and it didn't work out
but I apologized so honestly it's on you
if you're not gonna be emotionally
mature enough to accept my apology or at
least acknowledge that I apologize I
understand where I went wrong I
apologize not for what I did but for how
it affected you and I think that that
deserves some at least recognition if
not credit or you know some kind of like
dialogue if you want to well that being
said if you if you're if you're nervous
or shy because I am an incredibly
incredibly incredibly famous and
handsome celebrity absolutely the word
celebrity applies to this guy right here
so I can understand if you're nervous
but at the same time you got out you got
to talk to me at some point here you and
I
you and I were in this we're in this
like this we're in this like this and so
yeah I just I want you to feel
comfortable okay all right you know what
I gave you a chance and that's probably
the last chance I'm gonna give you I
really tried here I really thought that
you were finally gonna open up once and
for all but it looks like I'm just here
on my own making a fool out of myself
for trusting you and to be perfectly
honest Oh fool me once shame on me fool
me twice shame on me
yeah you you know what I mean it and if
you're if you're not gonna like let me
try to make a bridge like if we're on
two sides of a river right you're
emotionally over in Cincinnati I'm in
Cano let's switch that I'm in Cincinnati
you're in Kentucky the Ohio River is in
between us you're I'm building a bridge
I'm I'm building I'm I'm building the
bridge over to you like emotionally this
is like this is emotions not real Audi
but I'm building my bridge but I'm
building over to you you're not building
back so we're not able to connect
because the bridge does only work if you
meet in the middle
you can't build from one to the other
you gotta meet in the middle so you
gotta meet in the middle and you're not
meeting me in the middle and I'm not I'm
not uh I'm just not feeling it I think
that you should um be better about it I
think I think you should be better about
it I think I think you should be better
about it so just like think about the
bridge think about the bridge think
about connecting over the bridge okay so
another analogy I'm the parachuter
you're the parachute I pull the cord
then you open that's how it works that's
how it works
like I'm the penis you're the condom I
unwrap the wrapper then you jump out
all right all right well thank you for
your time
lovely home I have an appointment so I
will see you in the next video ba ba ba
ba ba
[Music]
yeah
yeah look at me look at me
Wow
oh do I wha man I do you know I do you
know I do
Oh minute seven I think I was talking to
my but at minute seven mmm that was the
good speech okay you don't need to you
don't need to mention that that was
weird that's a little rude you know
anyway okay thank you for using any way
and not anyways which is not
grammatically correct that's a good
thing about you I think it's about time
we had a head on home I was about to say
the same thing I had a great time I
don't always say any more of your time
oh don't don't worry about it I got to
know myself which is more important than
anything but before you go mmhmm yeah
oh you got me something oh oh you
shouldn't have
oh come on it's not much oh I bet it's
something I bet you went all out for it
I hate well I don't hate surprises if
they're good ones so come on what have
you got for me oh I have been working
really hard lately thank you okay ready
[Music]
do I open my eyes now
Oh Oh open okay whoa-oh-oh
wait a minute
hi well well what the heck just see you
oh I was working hard and I okay are you
look I can't I can't even believe this
right now I was working hard and this
isn't a good gift look I'm not one to
usually insult it's the thought that
counts but you didn't think you thought
with your your your nips and not your
butt you guys think with your butt when
you're getting me a gift do you know do
you know do you know how famous I am do
you know do you know do you know how
incredibly handsome I am I mean it's
obvious you look at me I don't deserve
to be treated this way I am special I am
a step above I mean I am just look at me
I deserve better and you are treating me
with disrespect and I don't appreciate
that I think you guys need to realize
how important I am and how essential I
am to this entire operation that you
have here you wouldn't even be here
without me you understand that you
understand you you're messing with now
you would not even know who I was unless
I told you and I did therefore you
should know well I'm sorry I didn't mean
to outburst like that
I really didn't know I'm sorry I didn't
mean to do that you you're lovely it's
not your fault it's not your fault in
fact I'm wondering you if I'm not
talking to a megaphone in the ceiling
and I'm actually talking to you mr.
button yeah I must say it yeah I don't
even care anymore I'm not even gonna ask
cuz you're not answering
cuz yet bridge ya fell down it collapsed
the condom no go on the pee pee the
parachute no saved me for a flat flat
and you need to understand that I only
have so much patience I can come up with
analogy after analogy after analogy but
unless you're willing to me
me halfway like I'm I'm sorry I'm just
I'm not I'm not gonna I'm not gonna have
patience for this I'm not gonna pace
them for it you know I just like you
know just look I just can't I can't okay
all right I just can't
[Music]
oh you're still here okay okay oh all
right okay all right you know I I was
the bigger man
I was the bigger man but you're gonna
need to apologize from to me if you're
if you want my forgiveness if you want
my forgiveness you're gonna need to
apologize to me I'm waiting I'm waiting
yeah okay I'm not hearing it you know
what that's fine that's whatever bygones
can be bygones it's fine I'm not worried
about it huh
bottom corner of left wall wait a minute
oh we do LA what's this ooh what's ooh
what's it say I can't read it is there a
way to crouch Oh can't crouch but
there's something there oh boy what do
we got here what do we got what does it
say anybody able to decipher this under
five get a prize is it like five foot
cuz I'm over five feet I am it's true I
am so I'm not gonna get a prize it's
probably not even a height thing it's
probably not even it-it's probably like
a time thing and I like it's too late I
can't get it so even if I were under
five feet tall which I'm not it probably
wouldn't even give me a prize if I did
it maybe I should maybe I should push it
maybe I should push it maybe I should
push it like maybe maybe maybe maybe I
should push it look call me call me call
me crazy but like I think it's like some
subliminal marketing thing like I kind
of like like what they got going on
here I kinda enjoy though theme to this
how I didn't like it at first like the
red but like a bowl I'm coming towards
the red you know what I'm saying
red red we could have a lot incoming I
could push this button
I think I'd enjoy it that's it gonna
enjoy it I probably get like a thrill
out of it woo if I did if I imagined I
did I'm probably not brave enough to
actually push it but you know it just
imagine if I did like what if I did push
it can you imagine that you're probably
like parent whoa and then it'd be so
cool right yeah I was like oh I in
school I didn't push button so house may
be my chance like maybe there's my
chance if it's my chance like I could
I'm not I'm not brave really I probably
won't I I might though I might by should
right yeah and school is lonely and I'd
know no friends no one knowing to push
buttons with now it's different cuz I'm
alone and with no friends but I've got a
button but I there's a button in and I
could push it I could I could I could I
bet I could I bet I could I'm real brave
like I'm I'm pretty I'm brave everyone
knows that about me all my friends that
totally exists say I'm brave and I'm
definitely over five feet tall you think
anyone like catch me if I did you think
I'd get in trouble if I push the but I
don't want to risk it you know it's
probably dangerous I don't want to get
hurt I got a lot going for me right now
so I
I shouldn't I shouldn't do it I really
shouldn't do it I I mean I'd like to I
mean I would but I don't talk about
anymore Owen talk about something else
talk about something else I don't like
talking about my high school days this
has been a nerd it got shunned a lot
don't I'm not a nerd no you're a nerd
you're I'm not a nerd I'm not a nerd no
I'm not I it took many years to leave
that life behind I'm not a nerd no no
look I'm not I'm cool I could push it
I'm cool enough to push it I'm cool I
would this is not the right time I could
just like try to do something else and
then I'd like do that thing look I'm not
a it's okay if I was it's okay
I wasn't heard I'm not but I'm not but
it'd be okay if I was just like you know
if that prize was for people under five
feet then maybe like if I did that then
maybe it would be okay like in fact
there was a cool prize in it under five
get a prize I'm not buddy I got a card
not a nerd fine whatever it's okay you
know I don't even need it you know I'm
not gonna look at any more I'm not gonna
look at you know I'm not even gonna look
at it because my whole life people have
been telling me that I've been going the
wrong way and you know what maybe maybe
it's my way maybe it's the way that I
pick maybe it's what I want maybe it's
what I want and not what everyone else
is telling me
maybe my butt was right mayo should
listen myself hey you got a minute okay
cool so I got a problem here right so
I'm playing this game and there's a big
red button here yeah there's a big red
button and it's like there's lights and
there's like words saying push the
button and there's like arrows pointing
at the button and there's like there's
just like a lot of motivational posters
about pressing this button they say that
the busting button will help me become
Who I am the arrows are red yeah the
button is red as well yeah
there's gold does that count yeah wait
no there's a pin up there's this girl
she's got a yellow dress yeah there's a
little yeah little yellow although that
might be gold too I'm not it might be
actually now that I'm looking at it's
like a metallic sheen to it I think that
might actually be gold Oh yellow yellow
yellow wait yeah yellow big poster
backgrounds yellow that's definitely
yellow
she's even telling me to push the button
on the sign - so you think I should
[Music]
there is yellow somewhere yeah does it
matter that all the text is white well
my gut told me to not press the button
my gut specifically told me not to press
the button you think but my heart told
me to press it and then my gut
countermanded and then like my left hand
said to president my right hand and said
not to press it my butt told me to
believe in myself and not listen to
outward opinions and Here I am calling
you for an hour depending but you need
to click the mouse button to press the
button it's not like an heed button it
oh good point
[Music]
that's yeah you're right I didn't even
think about that I'm not in control here
my right hand is appreciated you're
always the voice of reason here and I
appreciate it every time you give me
some advice oh sorry connects driving Oh
anyway um yeah so that's really the
problem here like the crux of the issue
isn't even us it's not about it's not
about me it's not about this not about
me it's to you it's always been about
you like I trusted you I still trust you
but I don't know if I can trust you
because after what left he told me left
he wants to push the button now I don't
want to create a scenario where lefties
reaching over you cuz really you are the
mouse person left he's the keyboard
person like I don't want to get in the
way of this like this is a good dynamic
so we got to reach an understanding and
I know you two don't like me right now
it's fine I get it
I listen to my ass a lot more than I
listen to you guys but we got to
cooperate gotta cooperate so I'm having
an internal conversation you guys don't
need to be a part of this I'm really
speaking internally about this too
Oh
[Music]
all right uh he doesn't want to do it so
that's the end of story we're just not
gonna be able to do it so yeah that's
that's the end all right cool we're good
we found out we got it all understood
and I think I think we're in agreement
like I've really discovered a lot about
myself and like the various parts of me
I I I get I get to know myself and
that's that's important and I think
that's really really important this has
been fun it has been fun this has been
fun I I really have learned a lot about
this I think we've all learned I think
you guys have learned I think all of us
has learned something about themselves
like in this whole time have you even
thought about consulting your various
body parts have you thought about their
opinions on the matter
have you really spoken to yourself
internally have you cuz I doubt it like
I mean I mean honestly I want to know I
want to know these conversations that
you have so like record a conversation
of you having the conversation a real
honest open heart conversation with your
heart and really get to the point of the
matter get to know who you are as a
person understand their wants their
needs their desires they may fight on
occasion but I always remember your but
knows best your but always knows what's
best to listen to your but before you
listen to your heart and then listen to
your gut after you consult your left
hand and then maybe maybe rely on your
right hand if your nips aren't speaking
up too much and your tootsies are
actually bringing their a-game make
sense it always does feel free go right
now speak to yourself and learn what it
means to really be the human [ __ ] no I'm
getting back into that conversation
again sorry sorry button I didn't mean
to bring that up again I know that
you're not human unless you are are you
wait a minute
hang on is there a reason you keep oh is
there a reason that you're not facing me
oh I knew it you don't want to show me
your backside because I'll see the
zipper on your costume oh I guess huh
who's this Ashton Kutcher could ash
ketcham joey graceffa is at you that you
I knew it oh boy I knew it I knew it
what the hell man what the hell you
ain't gonna press you you always try to
give me like this now I ain't gonna
happen
ah I can't believe it I was fell for it
I almost fell for it
oh god damn it I've been Punk'd oh man I
can't believe that I can't believe that
I was I was this close I was this close
to pushing you and then you would have
been jump out and you would be like ah
you pushed my penis or something tonight
man it would have been whoo doin crazy
are you filming this third camera here
wait there was a megaphone I should have
known
like I knew actually I think I knew I
really knew I knew that there was
something I did I knew like I knew oh
man I was onto you I was onto you from
now I was onto you from the beginning I
knew I knew there's a crazy Frank I
should have known that's not really
Uncle Sam oh that's not really Obama oh
I knew it
ah okay maybe you got me a little bit
there maybe maybe just a little bit all
over come on it's not that oh it's
pretty funny okay it's pretty funny all
right well anyway we had fun we had fun
we had fun but you know you mind if I
just hang out for a little longer like I
mean it's cool place you got in here III
don't think I really like took advantage
of like your hospitality so I think I'll
just like chill for a bit like I can
call an uber but it'll take a little bit
to get here so might as well be here
yeah
oh boy anyway so how you doing you good
you good oh come on you can drop the
silent treatment now come on it's just
you and me in here oh wait sorry stop
the cameras hello stop recording you can
come out now it's okay all right look
you you and I I get you we get each
other we get each other you were putting
up a good front i i was i was like
Tootsie's down my throat i i had no i
was like i was all confused you
you almost got me but I am just too
clever for you sorry if I ruin the
footage sorry I really do I can do it
again you want me to do it you're gonna
do it again let me do it again
wait no okay I'll do it again alright
I'll go they'll do it again RAL
Oh what's what's this place oh I don't
know where I owe
[ __ ] a red button I don't know if I
should well there's a lot of languages
here that maybe I should I mean if I
really think about it too much I do oh
look at the posters oh wow ooh ten out
of ten doctors I just will I don't know
if I should well maybe I'll just tip at
Oh a tip a tote but yeah oh no no sorry
I'm not I'm not a very good actor so I
have probably that's okay like it if
it's ruined it's ruined like we do our
best but if it's not you know there's
only so much you can do about it
hey I'm sorry if it did we uh maybe
maybe next time you get me an OL or
really understand each other better than
but you know you know don't be so
obvious next time don't be so obvious
there yeah I know
I know it's up yeah mmm still gonna be
another like another 15 minutes before
my uber gets here so um yeah um you got
like snacks or anything like that I'm
kind of hungry so if you if you got
anything like an like munch on dad be
great if you have anything if you got it
you have it and you need it and you give
it to me that'd be that'd be cool you
know yeah I mean it's not cool just
prank someone like this and then not
give craft services or anything like
that oh well whatever I guess it's okay
no that's fine don't worry about it I'm
sorry do you say something no oh sorry
okay I'm just gonna don't mind me I'm
just gonna I'm uh I'm gonna like I'm
like let's go I'm not it's not cuz I
don't want to talk like I just I play
around my phone a little bit nothing
seems to be a peer
maybe I'll tweet something I don't know
I've been able to tweet in a while sir
probably get more on
I'm gonna be like sighs should produce
something inspirational I know I know
what I'm gonna tweak always believe in
your but yeah I always believe in your
but that's pretty good I think people
like that I think people who get a lot
out of that I'll be pretty cool pretty
inspirational
yeah I'm pretty inspirational I'm pretty
good yeah a lot of people a lot of
people look up to me yeah I'm like
people people you know people look up to
me a little bit I don't want to be
conceited or anything I don't want to I
don't be conceited at all you know it's
fine people look up to me a little bit
yeah you know but I just wanna spread
the joy you know spread the joy I
learned I learned some things in my life
a lot of hard truths that I've had to
earn over the years I like to I like to
spread it around a little bit like a
little one oh you're sorry for calling
my butt and arrogant liar well you know
what you're forgiven
you're forgiven we're all human Oh Shh
no see I was caught in the loop there
you're you're you're human I know you
are I know you're we're all human
well made mistakes that's okay because
you can make a mistake and then you just
gotta keep moving keep moving forward
and that's what's really about feel like
we bonded really closely here all cool
there's so many so many so many people
that are responding so well to my tweet
there oh hell yeah oh hell yeah you
always got to believe in your but you
always always
you can't not believe in your but like
that's the most important thing in your
life who's always got your back who's
always behind you 100% who's always
supporting you supporting you who would
put your needs above their own hmm none
other than your butt your butt always
will your butt always does so just
remember that you can always believe in
your butt
maybe someday you'll have doubt in your
butt but your butt will always believe
in you now that's important that's
essential that's the thing that we all
as humans need to realize and spread
love around the world spread but love
all around the world I think that's the
true match to cheer spread but love all
around the world spread hashtag but love
spread
tag but love all around the world I
think that might be my hashtag that
might be my hashtag spread hashtag but
love all around the world
cuz you gotta love your but if you don't
love your but who are you and you got
teach people you gotta teach people that
with me love there but you too will love
your butt and everyone will love it but
it's a trust in your butt and your butt
will always have your back but love is
trending already you guys are oh you
guys are a dream I'm gonna check what's
in the hash tag oh my gosh I bet it's so
much positive oh it is oh you guys are
awesome oh my god you guys look at the
world oh my god well that's not but love
oh I'm gonna look at the photos oh no oh
that's not good that hashtag was oddly
enough already being used beforehand
oops okay alright anyway um oh ye oh boy
hi ye oh boy alright anyway I'm gonna
push the button I wasn't gonna wait 120
good god are you like my god even I like
45 minutes into that I was like uh I I
don't know if I can keep this up I don't
know if I keep going this way yeah the
game was like lagging the more and more
you went on the game was just like super
laggy and I have no idea but I'm lord of
yes I'll take that lord of the but
that's me baby that's me
all will loving despair you have passed
it says you will diminish and go into
the West Oh perfect hey let me try this
again
hey Luce doo-doo-doo let's sprint to the
one I'm gonna push o husain bolt and
yeah oh man that was that that was that
was a trip that was it
trip like I Wow oh boy I cannot believe
you guys stuck around for that why in
the world did you guys stick around for
that why what reason what reason do you
have to stick around for that oh my god
that was all that was awful that was
amazing that was amazing I'm impressed
with myself oh boy huh okay well whoa oh
there's four there's four other levels
what the hell I guess you just leave the
game on overnight but you have to go
through the door so you gotta leave it
running unlike unlike a side monitor the
whole night or on a laptop if you really
want those achievements oh my god
oh my god
[Music]